direction le sud et la rivière Langevin
mais loin des sentiers battus départ
pour une expédition hors du commun
public tu vas participer à l'équipement
de la voix à Mont de la cascade grand
galet et c'est du grand spectacle
donc le départ l'accès à la cascade en
ce moment c'est des petits rappels secs
dans lequel j'ai fait des lignes
aériennes pour préparer les gens les
mettent en condition à descendre la
Grande Cascade de Langevin qui existe
c'est un peu comme un crescendo
rythmique en musique il y a des petits
rappels d'accès au sec mais avec des
formes d'érosion qui sont magnifiques et
qui nous amènent en haut de cette
cascade qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
cet endroit on aura du général on la
voit de la route du point de vue en bas
et là du haut il y a une sensation de
vide qui est magistrale le bassin c'est
une autre translucide et puis le fait de
descendre dans cette cascade de la
découvrir du haut ben c'est c'est
magnifique c'est superbe quoi c'est
c'est un moment à vivre surtout au
niveau de la création au moment de la
création de l'équipement
le rappel c'est à dire la descente sur
corde à des sensations de glisse
comparables au ski c'est à dire que
l'intérêt d'avoir des équipements
performants juste avec un minimum de
frottement c'est qu'après ça laisse
libre cours à toutes les fantaisies on
peut descendre la tête la première
descendre un rappel 200 mètres en trois
secondes c'est à dire qu'on a pas de
souci sur des frottements de corde au
dessus on peut descendre très très vite
et là c'est des sensations de vitesse
qui sont très agréables
au niveau sensation c'est très
intéressant de créer des lignes là en
l'occurrence cascade de Langevin des
gens sont descendus dedans avant nous
mais pour des choses ponctuelles et les
équipements mis en place sont pas
forcément réutilisables par d'autres
donc c'est on peut pas considérer que le
canon est équipé pour être pratiqué le
fait de créer des lignes propres et
modernes
si c'est judicieux ça permet en
l'occurrence au niveau de la dernière
longueur ou de faire un rappel en
cascade ou de finir par nikyrolienne
comme là on a pu le faire ce qui donne
un aspect différent de la gestion de la
corde pour franchir des verticales
au moment de la création de l'île
moderne qui vont être c'est sûr
pratiquer maintenant c'est à dire qu'il
faut qu'on fasse la topographie qu'on a
diffuse parce que c'est un site
magnifique et quand on arrive dans le
bassin bon déjà moi je suis content la
création des lignes parce que ça se voit
avec le club avec lequel je suis à ce
moment-là que les lignes sont
performantes puisque je les vois passer
dessus donc c'est une sensation de
satisfaction du travail bien fait dans
un lieu magique où on va prendre plaisir
à emmener des gens c'est évident
le fait de rajouter un petit peu de
sensation à la verticalité qui est la
caractéristique majeure du début de la
cascade langerin c'est 5 rappels qui se
suivent donc c'est ça donne un aspect de
la cuvité canyon qui est plus complexe
que ça puisque elle comprend même temps
des sauts des toboggans de la nage et le
fait de pouvoir continuer dans la petite
partie aquatique en dessous ben ça fait
un tour